Passau a city located where two major
rivers merge and now experiencing its
worst flood disaster in centuries the
waters have begun receding leaving
behind debris and mud but residents are
cleaning up and determined to get back
to life as normal
rubber boots are essential equipment
here helpers have to trudge through
water and mud those without boots create
makeshift ones this volunteer has turned
a sturdy plastic bag into protective
gear she says all you need to do is tie
it around your foot and then around your
leg and that'll keep the mud out I'm a
fish I asked if it works
he says yesterday it held for three or
four hours but today he's tied the bags
a little tighter at this office at pasar
University Karolina Oberlander is
coordinating student volunteer efforts
the students are organized and doing
what they can it's nice she says that
pass our residents see that we're not
all lazy students we also roll up our
sleeves
we're residents too we want life to get
back to normal students have proven
ready to lend a hand two to three
thousand are helping out everyday in
Passau
one of the volunteers sent to the banks
of the in River is Barbara Graf who's
studying to become a teacher we're lucky
our own living quarters aren't affected
she says now that the water is gone it's
unbelievable how wrecked and full of mud
everything is but it's uplifting to see
everyone helping out but pass out isn't
free of the flood waters just yet as I
see when I join us or ''tis on Patrol
normally you would be able to stroll
along this promenade here now you
couldn't even stand on the spot
Bastian Brava is incredulous pregnant he
says it's shocking what nature is
capable of when you realize how
vulnerable you are in spite of
technology and flood defences there's
been a lot of investment here but in the
end Mother Nature was a meter higher
than expected passes location means it's
prone to flooding but never before has
it been this bad
the water has even crept up to places
previously considered safe that's been
the case for Vanek louse he wants to get
into his apartment and see just how bad
it is but he can't access it yet you
can't even see the house he says it's
located down a side street almost the
last house before the spot where the inn
and danube meet
he waves over the water police but they
can't dock the mud underneath is too
deep and currents are dangerous the most
direct way is blocked by piles of sand
and mud floor student and Gillick akarma
ought to be studying for her bar exams
but she says there are more important
things at the moment they've been
wheeling one load of mud after another
out of flooded businesses she says the
disaster is weighing on everyone's minds
Vanek house and his wife Hannah cuts are
worried about their home but they're
trying to look on the bright side
disasters always have a positive side
Hannah says when people show solidarity
and stand together that goes a little
way towards helping reduce the
devastation Barbara Graff and other
student volunteers have been assigned to
help clean out this bar that was
completely submerged all that's left is
mud and it's everywhere
the owner RAL cuca hadn't even been in
business for a year when the flood
struck
a firefighter once told him you have to
fight water with water the worst part
the mud is best cleared with more water
the bar was his hope for the future he
invested all his savings and took out a
loan from staff he says without
government assistance he won't be able
to pay back the money he still owes the
bank a normal salary wouldn't it be
enough without help he says he'll be
ruined for the next ten years
the senior living the 28 year old
doesn't even want to think about that
prospect right now at the moment he says
he's just grateful that he's not left
all alone with the cleanup work student
volunteer Barbara says Passau is
tight-knit studying here and taking
advantage of the city's offerings it's
only right to show solidarity and help
out
Vanek house and his wife Hannah Cutts
want to take stock and get to work
they're still hopeful of getting a ride
from the water police but they're told
the mud is nearly 2 meters deep to the
couple's disbelief the authorities say
it could take another two days until
they're able to reach their home Venna
Cal says apparently it's impossible
until the mud has been cleared all one
meter and 80 centimetres of it
the couple are now afraid that their
house could be covered in mud two vana
says that the houses further down
towards the river were built for floods
with living quarters elevated above
ground level but theirs is not they
never thought that water could rise so
high so fast they simply weren't
prepared sandbags weren't enough to hold
back the water with flood levels
reaching a peak of 12 metres 80 back at
the University Karolina Oh Belinda is
taking calls coming in by the minute
via the emergency hotline she asks what
people need pass our residents have also
been using Facebook to announce what
help they're looking for or are in a
position to give how Alena says a
student just called to ask for help for
an elderly neighbor who's lost
everything five volunteers are being
dispatched to help her gather her
belongings and to calm her nerves the
students Crisis Response has proven
effective
they've even put together care packages
with food for the volunteers students
say they packed cheese and sausage
sandwiches fruit and sweets and that
it's hopefully enough for the aid
workers the food has been donated by
passel businesses the care packages are
distributed to crews in the city center
a firefighter expresses surprised at the
quality of the students goodies and adds
that everyone's thankful for them even
the helpers say thanks in parcel and
this even dessert ice cream vendor tit
siano Damiano is giving out free
chocolate ice cream to volunteers
he says ice cream makes people happy
especially chocolate flavor it boosts
hormone levels and makes you smile that
way people's faces shine again like the
Sun people are happy when they can eat
ice cream and there's no more rain over
parcel anymore ice cream
always helps water police continue to
patrol and currents remain dangerous
bastian Pulver has been a member of the
volunteer water police brigade for
twenty years and this is his first major
test
there's marketing for fast it's fun to
help he says and you gain useful
experience he says it's a good way to
spend his leisure time another reason
everyone's eager to help is that Paso
depends on tourism and it's hoped that
visitors will want to return soon Hana
Katz wants to get into her home at last
she asks if this is the way her husband
has already managed to gain entry
supposedly by passing through this house
she can't believe the scenes around her
the water is waist high but luckily she
gets some assistance and she's grateful
for it it's unbelievable she says
finally she reaches her address the
floors are bending she exclaims again
she simply can't comprehend how high the
waters were but she's relieved that all
of her patient files in cabinets above
are secured she has a psychiatry
practice upstairs the floor is ruined
but at least her files have been spared
the damage could have been worse the
couple were evacuated from this balcony
several days ago
emergency crews rescued them with large
boats once the water reached dangerous
levels now many in Passau are wondering
how much their insurance will cover
this school gym should be usable again
in a matter of days but first some 35
centimetres of mud have to be cleared
Barbara calf is one of the volunteers
it's a different job this time she says
it's hard work but not impossible you
stay busy building custodian vana Gaia
is coordinating the 30 volunteer helpers
in his gym as a passel native
he's lived through a number of floods
this one he says has overwhelmed him
Passau hasn't experienced a flood like
this in 500 years but a robust community
spirit has also risen to the challenge